[Music]
deep inside Yale University's by Nikki
Rare Book and Manuscript library lies
the only copy of a 240 page tome
recently carbon dated to around 14 2000
meters feature looping handwriting and
hand drawn images seemingly stolen from
a dream real and imaginary plants
floating castles bathing women astrology
diagrams zodiac rings and Suns and moons
with faces accompany the text this 24 by
16 centimeter book is called the Voynich
manuscript and it's one of history's
biggest unsolved mysteries the reason
why no one can figure out what it says
the name comes from Wilfrid Voynich a
polish bookseller who came across the
document at a Jesuit College in Italy in
1912 he was puzzled who wrote it
where was it made what do these bizarre
words and vibrant drawings represent
what secrets do its pages contain he
purchased the manuscript from the
cash-strapped priest at the college and
eventually brought it to the US where
experts have continued to puzzle over it
for more than a century cryptologists
say the writing has all the
characteristics of a real language just
one that no one's ever seen before what
makes it seem real is that in actual
languages letters and groups of letters
appear with consistent frequencies and
the language in the Voynich manuscript
has patterns you wouldn't find from a
random letter generator other than that
we know little more than what we can see
the letters are varied in style and
height some are borrowed from other
scripts but many are unique the taller
letters have been named gallows
characters the manuscript is highly
decorated throughout with scroll like
embellishments it appears to be written
by two or more hands with the painting
done by yet another party
over the years three main theories about
the manuscripts text have emerged the
first is that it's written in cypher a
secret code deliberately designed to
hide secret meaning the second is that
the document is a hoax written in
gibberish to make money off a gullible
buyer some speculate the author was a
medieval con man others that it was
Voynich himself the third theory is that
the manuscript is written in an actual
language but in an unknown script
perhaps medieval scholars were
attempting to create an alphabet for a
language that was spoken but not yet
written in that case the Voynich
manuscript might be like the rongorongo
script invented on Easter Island
now unreadable after the culture that
made it collapsed though no one can read
the Voynich manuscript that hasn't
stopped people from guessing what it
might say those who believed the
manuscript was an attempt to create a
new form of written language speculate
then it might be an encyclopedia
containing the knowledge of the culture
that produced it others believe it was
written by the 13th century philosopher
Roger Bacon who attempted to understand
the universal laws of grammar or in the
sixteenth century by the Elizabethan
mystic John Dee who practice alchemy and
divination more fringe theories hold
that the book was written by a coven of
Italian witches or even by Martians
after 100 years of frustration
scientists have recently shed a little
light on the mystery the first
breakthrough was the carbon dating also
contemporary historians have traced the
Providence of the manuscript back
through Roman Prague to as early as 1612
when it was perhaps passed from holy
roman emperor rudolf ii to his physician
yacouba's sena pious in addition to
these historical breakthroughs
linguistic researchers recently proposed
the provisional identification of a few
of the manuscripts words
could the letters beside these seven
stars spell Turin a name for Taurus a
constellation that includes the seven
stars called the Pleiades could this
word be Cintron for the Centurion plant
in the picture
perhaps but progress is slow if we can
crack its code what might we find the
dream journal of a 15th century
illustrator a bunch of nonsense or the
lost knowledge of a forgotten culture
what do you think it is
[Music]
you